this was a joint investigation by the
Nordic public broadcast team who were
investigating Russian spy ships with a
particular focus on the Admiral of
vladimisky here shown here and this is
one of these ghost ships it had turned
off its identification electronic
identification equipment and although
the Russians have said that it's on
scientific research program if you look
at it it's covered in an array of
Aerials and Radars all of which indicate
a very different purpose for it now the
Nordic program said that this was spying
in the seas around the UK well this is
not new for somebody like myself who
served in the military for many decades
the the Russians and the Soviets before
them always used to have ships around
the UK listening and watching the only
difference is they used to call them
trawlers and even though there was no
evidence of Nets or fish that was their
excuse for operating but of course with
increased tensions for in the Russian
invasion of Ukraine inevitably there's a
worry about more Sinister intent but
what does this thing actually do what it
does is listen away it's the eyes and
the ears the Russians is looking at
things like typhoons when they operate
up in the north of the country operating
our quick reaction alert they're
watching our tactics they're watching
um any shortfalls or any critical
vulnerabilities but the ship can also go
around to the West Coast look into the
Clyde watch how our submarines are
operating and can also go down to the
South Coast down to Portsmouth and watch
the Queen Elizabeth class operating
there and increasingly it's looking
below the ocean to actually see the
critical National infrastructure what's
particularly interesting that this
revealed was last year Norway revealed
that one of its undersea data pipelines
had been severed they're not quite sure
what caused it but it could have been an
actor sabotage and in the uh and also
the Danish Defense Force took 112
pictures of Russian ships if you
remember the Nordstrom pipeline blown in
on the 26th of September last year and
these Russian ships some of them had
cranes some of them had submersibles all
of which it doesn't prove anything but
it certainly points the finger of guilt
that key issue here though is there's
that since my day in the military is a
massive increase in sub-surface critical
National infrastructure in the North Sea
it's fairly shallow it's pretty easy to
track that stuff but there's also an
element of um of redundancy there but
across if you look West for across the
North Atlantic some of the data
pipelines there they're very deep hard
to track but they are critical uh
vulnerability and also as the Europe has
weaned off its dependency on Russian Oil
we're now very heavily dependent on
Norwegian oil and gas all of which is
provided by undersea pipelines it just
shows the critical vulnerability that we
have to these sorts of capabilities